- Hey guys this is Evan
Carmichael, my one word
is believe and I believe
that all the world's
major problems will be
solved by entrepreneurs.
So to help you on your path,
today we're going to learn
nine surprising facts about
Alibaba founder, Jack Ma.
(soft techno music)
- Fact number one, he used
to guide tours for free
in China for nine years to
learn new ways of thinking.
- For nine years, every
morning, almost, whether snow,
rain or sun, I went there
looking for foreign tourists
to become the free guide.
And I made a lot of friends.
This trained me the way
of think different from
the other kids in China, my generation.
'Cuz everything I learned
from the tourists,
foreign tourists are so different
from the things I
learned from the schools,
my parents because we
thought China was like that,
the world was like that, in our books.
But the thing that I learned from outside
they are so different.
So that trained my way
of thinking different.
When people talk about everything,
when everything people agree,
normally I take one minute
to think about is that true?
When everything disagree, I
say take about a one minute,
think about it, hmm, is that true?
So that was a training.
- Fact number two, his
hero is Forrest Gump.
- The hero I had is Forrest Gump.
Fourteen years ago when,
- Want some chocolates?
- Yeah.
- You know he's a
fictional character though.
- I really like that guy,
I've been watching that movie
for about 10 times.
Every time when I'm
frustrated, I watch the movie.
And I watch movie before
I came here, again.
- [Co-host] What are you doing?
- Yeah, for coming to the New York,
because I watch the movie again,
and telling me that, no
matter whatever changed,
you are you, and I'm still the guy,
15 years ago, I only
earn like $20 a month.
And today I can do that much, you know.
- Fact number three, he has
no technical background,
started with one dollar in his pocket,
and beer was the first thing
that he searched on the internet.
- And when I go to register
company called, internet,
the registry office said
no, there's no such word,
internet in the dictionary,
how can you register an internet.
So they say, you have to
register another name,
I said what's the name?
He said, Computer Consulting Firm.
And I have no idea about what is computer.
So my first company,
Hangzhou Hope Computer Consulting Firm.
It was tough, without knowing
anything about technolog,
without knowing anything about computer,
in the past 15 years, I've been working.
I call myself like a blind man,
riding on the back of the blind tigers.
(audience laughing)
Those experts riding
horses, they all fell.
We survived because we
worry about the future.
We believe the future, we change ourself,
we never compete the others.
- Fact number four, is life is full
of failures and rejections.
- Tried to get into three colleges.
Each time they rejected you.
- No, I tried, there's a
examination, that young people,
if you want to go university you have
to take the examination.
So I failed it three times.
But I have a lot of fail.
I fail for funny things that I failed
a key primary school test for two times,
and I failed, three times
for the middle schools.
You would never believe,
in Hangzhou, my city,
there's only one middle school,
that last only one year.
It was change from primary
school to middle school,
because I want our
graduates of our school,
no middle school accept us,
because we were too bad.
So we become a middle school.
When I graduate from universities,
and before, for three years,
I tried and failed in the universities,
so apply jobs for 30 times, got rejected.
I went for a police, they
said, "no you're not good."
I went to even the KFC,
when KFC come to China,
come to my city,
- [Host] You applied.
24 people went for the job,
23 people accepted, I
was the only one guy.
And we went for police, 5 people,
4 of them accepted, I was
the only guy that receive it.
So to me, being turned down, rejected,
oh by the way, I told you
that I apply for Harvard,
for 10 times rejected.
(audience laughs)
I know they reject, I just want to see ...
- They're sorry now.
Ten times you wrote them and said,
"I'd like to come to Harvard."
- Yeah. And then I told myself,
someday I should go teach there probably.
(audience laughing)
- Fact number five, he
chose the name Alibaba,
because he liked the open sesame story.
- Why did you call the company Alibaba?
- I like the spelling
and I like the vision,
Ali Baba open sesame.
I believe the internet is open sesame,
and there is pass world to everybody,
that you can find the great people,
you can find a great
opportunities of business,
and improve people, that
is open sesame story.
I love the Alibaba, it saves
me a lot of marketing dollars.
When I started, I think,
Internet is global,
we should have global name.
And a name that, interesting like,
at that time the best name is Yahoo.
So I been thinking for many days,
suddenly thinking, Alibaba is good name.
So I was happen to be in
San Francisco that day.
I have a lunch, and the waitress come.
I ask her, do you know about Ali Baba?
She say, "Yes", I say,
"What is Ali Baba?",
she say, "Open sesame."
Good.
So I went down the street,
I ask about 10, 20 people.
They all know about Ali
Baba, forty thieves,
and open sesame, and I
think, this is a good name.
Start with A, what ever you talk about,
Alibaba is always top.
- Fact number six, he learned
English by watching TV,
because there were no other
options in China at the time.
- Think, there is no way to
learn English at that time.
There's no teachers in our city,
who can teach people to speak English.
So I listen to the BBC
and Voice of America.
And there, every evening, nine o'clock,
eight o'clock to nine
o'clock, I open my video,
Monday, Wednesday, and
Friday, I listen to the VOA,
the first book I heard about
is the Adventure of Tom Sawyer.
- Fact number seven.
He performs mass weddings
for his employees.
(upbeat music)
(speaking foreign language)
- Fact number eight, he
wants to retire early,
explore other interests,
and die on a beach.
- People say this is a uncertain world.
Every day's uncertain, the
only certain day was yesterday.
I'm not sure about that in the future,
I will dictate, I will be stupid,
that's why I should retire
early, when I'm young.
That is why I have a lot
of things that I dream
I want to do, I want to do philanthropy,
I want to be a teacher, I
want to go back to school,
I want to do the environment.
And the world is so wonderful,
why should it be the sea
of Alibaba all the time?
I'm come in to this world not to work.
I want to come to this
world to enjoy my life.
I don't want to die in my office,
I want to die on the beaches.
- Fact number nine, he
once dressed up and sang
the Lion King theme song to his employees.
- [Narrator] I'd worked
as a vice-president
in his company for nearly ten years.
As our team survived the Internet bubble,
fought a war with Ebay, and
managed to build China's first
global internet company,
I settled into my seat and wondered,
how would Jack address us
on this important night?
And then, just like any other billionaire
in the same situation,
Jack took the stage.
(singing in foreign language)
♫ Can you feel the love tonight
- [Narrator] Well, it
may not have been typical
for a company chairman,
but it wasn't surprising coming from Jack.
People outside the company
assumed he was crazy,
but those of us inside
the company knew better.
- So guys, thank you so much for watching,
I hope you enjoyed.
I'd love to know what was
the most surprising fact
that you learned about
Jack Ma in this video,
leave it in the comments below,
really curious to see
what you have to say.
Thank you so much for watching,
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself,
and whatever your one word is,
much love.
I'll see ya soon.